mi más grande visión a nivel profesional
es impulsar a más personas a que
alcancen su máxima carrera a través de
internet durante varios años me he
dedicado a viajar y como un hobby
personal me ha gustado sentarme en cafés
de múltiples lugares y escribir al
respecto escribir sobre el éxito
empresarial sobre cómo alcanzar mejores
equipos sobre con quién trabajar
durante estos escritos empecé a formar
una audiencia y este año llegue a mi
suscriptor número 3000 3000 personas que
me leen constantemente sobre cards sobre
éxitos de carrera y cómo ser mejor
profesional día a día y les mandé en
este último correo para celebrar cuál
era los retos profesionales más grandes
que tenían estas 3.000 personas reciben
múltiples respuestas pero habían dos
factores importantes que les preocupaban
los dos factores importantes eran uno
cómo puedo vender más y dos cómo puede
encontrar un trabajo muchísimo más
rápido algo algo que es muy importante
con esto es que cuando yo leía todo
todos los los correos no solamente
venían las respuestas sino venían muchas
inquietudes miedos falta de confianza en
uno mismo para poder desarrollar más
allá nuestras carreras
yo lo que la manera en cómo lo aborde
fue que no estas dos estos dos factores
no son independientes vienen son una
consecuencia de algo más para poder
responder esta pregunta de cómo obtener
más de estas oportunidades la forma en
como yo lo determine fue a través de
esta pregunta si las y las oportunidades
no son aleatorias entonces de qué
depende
de ahí empecé a trabajar diferentes
teorías y esta es una de las teorías que
más me ha funcionado a nivel de
consultoría y cuando estoy trabajando
con los equipos alrededor mío las
oportunidades profesionales parten de
entender primero tres tendencias primero
que las empresas como tal tienen sus
propias tendencias que la tecnología
está avanzando por si mismo y también es
otra tendencia estar atento y la tercera
tendencia es la parte social una última
tendencia que a pesar de que no la
tomamos tanto en cuenta y sucede
rápidamente también debemos estar
pendientes cuando nosotros entendemos es
tras estas tres tendencias es cuando
culminamos en un concepto llamado marca
personal relevante y es aquí cuando la
empezamos a desarrollar es cuando
realmente desarrollamos oportunidades
profesionales
quiero hablarles de las tres tendencias
y cómo está abordando se al día de hoy y
a partir de ahí también cómo se conectan
entre ellas para llegar a la marca
personal relevante este concepto al cual
yo estoy utilizando mucho dentro de los
procesos de consultoría lápiz dentro de
las empresas y la tendencia las
tendencias empresariales se encuentra la
psico psicología organizacional hay
muchos escritos de múltiples personas en
harvard business review en múltiples
revistas especializadas en eeuu sobre
cómo puedo atraer al equipo correcto
todos nosotros tenemos negocios o
formamos parte de un negocio y nuestro
más grande miedo es saber si vamos a
encajar si nosotros con nuestro talento
y convicción vamos a poder ser un feed
cultural con la empresa hay muchos
estudios sobre cómo podemos nosotros
encontrar el feed cultural con la
empresa correcta pero no de los de los
escritos y de las teorías que más me
encantan es este escrito de rr juan en
el cual habla de que para que una
persona pueda ser exitosa en su carrera
debe de haber tres variables importantes
la primera es la compatibilidad social
la compatibilidad social
habla de que que tan buenos somos para
gestionar nosotros mismos y después qué
tan buenos somos para gestionar personas
habla sobre liberar habla sobre que
también nosotros podemos hablar con los
equipos de manera empática y agradable
habla de qué tan bueno somos siendo
estrictos en el momento correcto habla
de qué manera podemos enganchar
departamentos si podemos construir redes
con nuestros clientes y proveedores toda
esa parte social tan importante que las
empresas no toman mucho en cuenta que si
tenemos que desarrollarnos y que de
alguna forma también es incluyente
dentro de nuestra marca personal
relevante un segundo punto es la que es
la habilidad técnica la habilidad
técnica como tal tenemos que
desarrollarla todo el tiempo es una
responsabilidad nuestra de estar
aprendiendo de nuestros sectores todo el
tiempo y se enfoca a que seamos capaces
de hacer el trabajo tiene que ver mucho
que ver con las habilidades cognitivas
hay muchas empresas que utilizan el like
you' para poder saber qué tan hábiles
técnicamente somos pero esto es otra de
las tendencias que está habituando
dentro de la parte empresarial que tan
habilidoso eres con tú con tu nivel
técnico
y la tercera que las empresas también
buscan y que usualmente no nos la
cuentan pero que existe es la ambición
cuando nosotros entramos a una empresa
podemos notar que hay colaboradores que
son mucho más ambiciosos que otros hay
colaboradores que se entregan más por la
empresa que otros que le dedican más
tiempo que arriesgan más y aunque las
empresas no lo cuenten esto es muy
importante desarrollar esto implica que
tenemos que saber en qué empresas
queremos trabajar nosotros no solamente
está vinculado con entrar a trabajar y
ya sabemos que hay empresas en las
cuales podemos ser más felices y que si
nosotros tenemos estamos en el lugar
correcto nuestra ambición va a
desarrollarse mucho más y también pues
eso va a ayudarnos a superarnos
emocionalmente este es uno de los
escritos de re hogan es un escrito
bastante fuerte sobre cómo las empresas
están contratando pero hay muchos hay
una tendencia empresarial de cómo
encontrar equipos de alto desempeño el
siguiente la siguiente tendencia que
nosotros estamos abordando para obtener
oportunidades profesionales es la
tecnología en este momento estamos
encontrando mucho
muchas variables interesantes como es la
inteligencia artificial las aplicaciones
inteligentes las plataformas
interconectadas solamente les puedo
decir que con la tecnología a pesar de
que haya toda una explicación enorme y
cada una tenga su tiempo todos ellos
están tomando datos de nosotros todo lo
que escribamos en facebook tiene sentido
lo que escribamos en linkedin tiene
sentido lo que escribamos en nuestro
blog tiene sentido y se conectan entre
ellos hoy en día es muchísimo más fácil
que un reclutador no le haga caso a un
currículum vitae y se meta a entrar
entre google y busque exactamente quién
eres la tecnología como tal va a seguir
empujando a seguir acaparando nuestros
datos y es nuestra responsabilidad
también estar conscientes de ello y dos
que podamos nosotros ir alineando lo
mejor de nosotros dentro de esos datos
para que tengamos más oportunidades
también una tercera tendencia es la
parte social aquí hay muchas aristas
pero puntualmente me encanta saber que
podemos viajar más estamos en la era
donde podemos viajar a cualquier parte
del mundo podemos cotizar podemos sacar
presupuestos y también podemos ir
encontrando opciones es muchísimo más
fácil asistir a un evento en san
francisco hoy en día que hace 20 años
tal vez será muchísimo más complicado
calcular presupuestos pero hoy es
muchísimo más fácil y también de ese
lado cuando nosotros empezamos a
entender que viajar y encontrar eventos
a nivel internacional de nuestro sector
es muchísimo más fácil
entendemos que hay muchísimas más
comunidades de diferentes sectores las
comunidades como tal y me encanta y me
encanta determinarlo es con una frase de
simon's inec uno de los expertos en
liderazgo a nivel internacional que una
comunidad es un conjunto de personas que
acuerdan crecer juntos cuando nosotros
hablamos de comunidades es un conjunto
de personas que deciden que vamos a
crecer entre todos y esto es muy
interesante porque cuando nosotros
empezamos siendo arquitectos siendo
abogados
programadores siendo ingenieros en algún
área tenemos que estar constantemente
buscando nuestras comunidades nuestras
tribus las tendencias sociales nos
invitan a que busquemos esas tribus para
crecer juntos entendamos que hoy en día
hacer los solos es un camino muchísimo
más tardado y de alguna manera no
debemos no debemos de tomar ese camino
difícil aprendamos entre todos y
crezcamos juntos estas tres tendencias
como tal están súper enlazadas las
tendencias tecnológicas empresariales y
sociales y de aquí entendemos qué
hacemos con estas tendencias
creamos las marcas personales relevantes
cuando nosotros entendemos nuestro
entorno es cuando nosotros ponemos a
pensar cómo jugamos en esas tendencias
las marcas personales relevantes por así
decirlo están están en el historial de
todo lo que nosotros comunicamos al
mundo un amar todos tenemos una marca
personal todos tenemos una reputación la
gente nos conoce por ciertas actividades
que hacemos pero la gran diferencia
entre una marca personal y una marca
personal relevante es que una marca
personal nosotros no tomamos control de
ella va sucediendo y al mismo tiempo
está enfocada en nosotros solamente
queremos mostrar lo que nosotros sabemos
pues marcas personales relevantes
nosotros queremos que más personas se
desarrollen
queremos que yo aprendo pero que tú
aprendas y es aquí cuando ya se está
dando un boom de marcas personales
relevantes y esta es la manera en cómo
está funcionando para poder generar una
marca personal relevante primero tengo
que determinar estas tres preguntas
quién soy qué quiero hacer y por qué
quiero hacerlo cuando nosotros tenemos
determinadas estas tres preguntas el
siguiente paso es comunicarlo
que todas las personas encuentren mis
propósitos quién soy porque estoy
luchando por esto y que sea muy fácil de
encontrar y no me persigan por tu
internet para saber dónde estoy
de aquí determinamos que las marcas
personales relevantes tienen cuatro
actividades la primera es la identidad
digital
nosotros como tal y lo comparto
muchísimo con las audiencias que tengo
con los equipos que lidero con todos los
proyectos a los cuales me involucro a mí
me interesa que todos tengan una
identidad digital
si alguien está buscando mike nueva en
google que encuentre todos los proyectos
en los cuales estoy involucrado y que
pueda atraer más personas sincronizadas
con la mentalidad que yo busco que no
que yo sé que en todo el planeta hay
personas que están peleando lo mismo que
yo y que yo sé que los tengo que atraer
y exponerme más para que ellos me
encuentran y poder charlar de tener una
identidad digital les permite tener
mayores socios tener mayores clientes
tener mayores alianzas trabajar donde
ustedes quieran
es muy importante tener hoy en día
nuestro propio dominio incluso magnet
puntocom es algo que hace 20 años
alguien se hubiera reído pero hoy en día
es algo muy primordial la siguiente es
la parte de proyectos todos debemos de
involucrarnos con proyectos de manera
voluntaria hay muchos proyectos que
están generando nuestro sector y que de
alguna forma salirnos de nuestro de
nuestra cotidianidad de estar haciendo
lo mismo todos los días nos involucra a
que cuando formamos de un proyecto de
manera voluntaria entendamos más cuáles
son los problemas qué
tenemos que resolver todos los días
nosotros vamos a trabajar nos levantamos
de la cama y tenemos constantemente
problemas que vamos a resolver pero más
allá tenemos que pensar cuál es el
problema principal que todos los
profesionales de nuestro sector estamos
resolviendo y apoyar a que sigamos
creciendo y desarrollarlo la tercera es
la parte de ser autoridad el
autodidactismo para hacer una marca
personal relevante no podemos dejar
nuestra educación en manos de alguien
más tenemos que aprender a ser nosotros
conscientes de que estudiar es de es una
es un hábito propio estudiar por nuestra
cuenta saber qué es lo que nos gusta
leer de múltiples autores inscribirnos a
los blogs de otras personas es parte de
ser autodidacta estudiar online como tal
es una de las tantas especialidades para
aprender pero consideremos que es muy
importante hoy en día no le dejen la
educación en manos de alguien más tomen
la ustedes y finalmente el idioma y
cultura el idioma como tal es algo muy
importante a valorar considerar que el
español lo amamos lo queremos
pero hay muchos otros idiomas el inglés
y el mercado anglosajón es maravilloso
muchos de mis amigos están fuera están
fuera de mexico y me han enseñado tantas
cosas me han invitado a tantos eventos
he tenido la oportunidad de abrirme
puertas en el extranjero por el simple
hecho de romper la barrera de que no
estoy solamente en mexico de que forme
parte de un mundo enorme y para poder
comunicarme con ellos necesito aprender
inglés el idioma y la barrera la barrera
de la cultura es algo que nosotros
tenemos que luchar para generar una
marca personal relevante quiero cerrar
mi charla con mostrarle a algunas marcas
personales relevantes que ha tenido
oportunidad de conocerlas y que de
alguna forma veo el gran cambio que está
impactando en sus comunidades
ella es tan ágil ella es una entrenadora
en la pasión es empresaria y me encanta
que cada vez que charló con ella me
platica sobre todas las familias que
llevan a sus pequeños a que aprendan a
nadar que la manera en cómo ellos
conectan entre familias es a través de
na 2 y a partir de ahí ella ella ha
escrito muchos muchos artículos sobre
cómo ser mejor deportista cómo nadar
mejor me encanta que la marca personal
trasciende más allá del solo yo sino más
bien de que más personas formen parte de
lo que yo busco que todas las personas
aprendan a nadar
y luego tenemos otra marca personal
relevante que sharon benítez tiene él
tiene una comunidad de más de 50.000
personas y en todo su camino como
empresario ha creado empresas ha
desarrollado personas en sus equipos él
escribe todo lo que él va reflexionando
a nivel empresarial y a pesar de que él
les sirve para entender qué está
sucediendo ha ayudado a múltiples
personas a generar negocios muchísimo
más profesionales está involucrado con
el tema de la tecnología está
involucrado con el tema de la educación
y escribir lo que uno siente piensa y
conecta es lo que le ha permitido llegar
a esa cantidad de audiencia que tanto
preside
él es la oro silva otra marca personal
relevante él empezó a generar contenido
para sí mismo a nivel de software él es
ingeniero en software y desarrolló
muchos artículos para poderse explicar
cómo desarrollar mejores aplicaciones
cuando las empresas saltar en línea en
inglés lo invitaron a muchos proyectos
en eeuu como hip hop para poderse
incorporar y es aquí donde yo me doy
cuenta de el gran impacto que nosotros
tenemos en nuestras letras en internet
él con sólo escribir ha podido ser
invitado a múltiples eventos y es parte
de nuestra intención con estas charlas
invitarnos también a que vean esta
oportunidad y con todas las tendencias
que tenemos en este regio safran él es
un director financiero pero su gran amor
y pasión es correr él ayuda a todas las
mañanas desde las 6 de la mañana hasta
las 9 de la mañana
ayuda a cerca de 500 maratonistas a ser
mejores profesionales es patrocinado por
empresas grandes como nike para que
forme parte e invite a formar comunidad
en bogotá él es uno de mis más grandes
amigos
y en el fondo él me cuenta que correr es
el deporte que le permite conectar con
más personas y ayudarlas y entenderlas y
al mismo tiempo él se desarrolla
físicamente es impresionante la marca
personal que tiene y es una marca
personal relevante finalmente él es mi
gastroenterólogo el doctor norberto
carlos chávez y cuando yo lo conocí él
me platicó de su marca personal
relevante me comentó que él quiere ser
un gran doctor
él es un gran médico que es un gran
médico pero él quiere seguir rompiendo
las fronteras y llegar a más países y lo
que me comentó fue que para lograrlo
creó una plataforma que se llama es mi
gastro y él internamente me contaba yo
prefiero mil veces que en vez de tener
mil pacientes haya prevenido mil
enfermedades porque mi misión más grande
no es tener más pacientes es tener menos
en donde el sentido en el sentido
económico sino más bien de que más
personas estén conscientes de que cuidar
cuidar la parte
el intestino grueso cuidara la parte de
nuestro estómago de la parte de nuestro
intestino delgado todo parte de hábitos
y tiene una misión y me encanta y la
promueve y tiene una comunidad de 15 mil
personas y me parece increíble que las
marcas personales relevantes estén
caminando hacia allá
quiero cerrar esta charla en considerar
que todos tenemos una marca personal
todos somos conocidos por algo y tenemos
mucha experiencia en nuestros ramos que
más personas la conozcan no dejen en
mano su educación conecten se con
comunidades sean autodidactas y al mismo
tiempo viajen por todo el mundo todos en
este momento pueden conectar con más
personas sincronizadas con ustedes hoy
es el momento hoy es el punto donde
todas las tendencias se intersectan es
momento de crear nuestras marcas
personales relevantes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]